[Music]
how can we state that but the truly Sun
lion don't leave the scent again I
besides gonna be our year I can feel it
you realize you don't war father ever
I'm not gonna let you ruin your lifetime
no drugs in the house
everything's fine not fine fine
Mosbacher fine let her talk stay out of
it put some clothes on will ya we're
going for custard
y'all know who my dad is right y'all
know what he saw I know your broke ass
daddy what you said your name was
where hey white boy Rick you got some
balls coming here like you did you
should come out of scam room sometime
we're not like this but like you robbed
a Kmart or something
you're good Rick you want to move wait
you come to me my dad finds this you'll
kick my ass just make sure he doesn't
find it then break it down the diamond
box
get yourself a pool and I'll float it
before long people in London legit
you're gonna get into deep man there I
can reach out a pounds 14 ounces such a
way you were born first time I looked in
your eyes I knew you were gonna be a big
[ __ ] when your life was gonna be bigger
than mine look at this dad
look how we're living let's hustle big I
know the players man I know the game hey
come on dad I can do this we can do this
we can fix our lives and be a family
again
what do you say
ask yourself this would you believe a
fifteen-year-old kid was working for the
federal government but it was what you
all got him
you